For this question you're asked to decide which of the procedures run in linear time.
That is, the running time scales linearly with the length of the input.
What we need to make sure is that there aren't too many steps.
If we have a look at the first procedure,
we initialize a variable--that doesn't take very much time.
Then we have a for loop, and the for loop iterates through the input list here.
If nothing happens in here, then it will iterate input list times.
In order for it to be linear, the steps within the for loop must be in constant time.
What are we doing?
We're just comparing the variable maximum with an element,
and then if the comparison is true, then we're setting maximum to be the element.
This is just looking for the maximum element in the list.
That's just a constant time operation there.
So that is constant time, so procedure 1 does run in linear time.
Now onto our second procedure. What's it doing?
It's taking the first element of the input list and adding it onto sum.
Sum starts at zero and then adds the first element of the input list,
and then the input list is set to be the second element onwards in the list.
Then it keeps summing. Now, how many steps does this take?
Well, it just cuts off the first element each time in the list.
That's the one that we've already added on.
Then the list continues as long as it's not empty.
This is actually performed the length of the input list times.
One thing we always need to look at when we're doing this
is to check whether they're constant time.
You're told in the question that both of these are constant time,
which means that the whole procedure runs in linear time.
Now onto procedure 3.
What it's doing is running through the list, checking each element against every other element.
If you're not checking at element against itself and the two elements are the same,
then return false.
Otherwise, return true.
It's checking whether there is a repeated element in the list.
Now, looking at how it's done it, this inner loop here runs through all the values of j.
In the worst case, when the input list of i is never equal to the input list j--
when i and j are different--this will run through the whole list.
This is going to go through length of input list times in the worst case.
The inner loop for j--that's going to go through that many times.
Now, it's going to go through that many times when i = 0 and when i = 1 and when i = 2 and so on.
It's actually going to go through that inner loop length of input times.
That's squared and if it's something squared, it's no longer linear.
So this is not linear time.
The correct answer was procedures 1 and 2 run in linear with respect to the input list,
and procedure 3 does not.